[Music]
[Applause]
my big idea is a very very small idea
that can unlock billions of big ideas
that are at the moment dormant inside us
and my little idea that will do that
is sleep
this is a room of type a women
this is a room of sleep deprived women
and i learned the hard way the value of
sleep
two and a half years ago i fainted from
exhaustion i hit my head on my desk i
broke my cheekbone i got five stitches
on my right eye
and i began the journey of rediscovering
the value of sleep
and in the course of that
i studied i met with medical doctors
scientists and i'm here to tell you
that the way to a more productive more
inspired more joyful life is getting
enough sleep
and we women are going to lead the way
in this new revolution this new feminist
issue
we are literally going to slip our way
to the top literally
because
unfortunately for men sleep deprivation
has become a virility symbol
i was recently having dinner with a guy
who bragged that he had only gotten four
hours sleep the night before
and i felt like saying to him but i
didn't say it i felt like saying you
know what if you had gotten five this
dinner would have been a lot more
interesting
there is now a kind of sleeve
deprivation one-upmanship
especially here in washington if you try
to make a breakfast date and you say how
about eight o'clock they are likely to
tell you eight o'clock is too late for
me but that's okay you know i can get a
game of tennis in and do a few
conference calls and meet you at eight
and they think that means that they are
so incredibly busy and productive but
the truth is they're not
because we at the moment have had
brilliant leaders in business in finance
in politics
making terrible decisions
so a high iq does not mean that you're a
good leader because the essence of
leadership is being able to see the
iceberg before it hits the titanic
and we've had far too many icebergs
hitting our titanics
in fact
i have a feeling that the lehman
brothers was lehman brothers and sisters
they might still be around
while all the brothers were busy you
know just being hyper-connected 24 7
maybe a sister would have noticed the
iceberg because she would have woken up
from a seven and a half or eight hours
sleep
and have been able to see the big
picture
so as we are facing all the multiple
crises
in our world at the moment
what is good for us on a personal level
what's going to bring more joy gratitude
effectiveness in our lives
and be the best for our own careers
is also what is best for the world
so
i urge you
to shut your eyes
and discover the great ideas that lie
inside us
to shut your engines and discover the
power of sleep thank you
[Applause]
25 of the world's food supply is lost to
spoilage that's 458 billion dollars
worth every year on a smarter planet
we're building intelligence into
physical things
so we can know how far our foods travel
monitor temperature all the way to the
market i know it got to the table fresh
it's already happening in places like
canada norway and vietnam when we make
food smarter we make it safer that's
what i'm working on i'm an ibmer let's
build a smarter planet